happy glorious monday everyone
you know ever since this show began in
the early 70s
as a summer replacement for the brady
bunch we were on top of one trend cancel
culture the idea being if your past
isn't adaptable to current standards you
would lose your friends social status
netflix password and career you'd be
shunned from polite society its kindred
spirit was wokism political correctness
on more steroids than lance armstrong
which allowed no forgiveness relating
not just to your past actions but to who
you are generally it's things that can't
be changed like your race or pete
davidson's bed sheets
in the world of the woke you're either
oppressed or the oppressor and the
offenses only flow in one direction
suddenly we no longer measure anyone by
achievement but by victim status which
creates a new kind of segregation that's
now spreading like omicron in the
olympic village i call it idea
segregation and that we cannot share our
knowledge wisdom or ideas if we're not
of the same tribe now we see this with
crime this show has been blaring about
rising crime like the alarm at a broken
nordstrom's window but the people who
need to hear it won't listen because
it's coming from us
it's the fox crying wolf
they'd rather drown in raw sewage than
grab a life preserver from us meetings
and i get it it affects all issues from
the border to crime to covet it's a
division of ideas and none shall mix now
imagine if this kind of thing existed
before we had a chance to make things
like did you ever wonder about how a
pencil is made
milton friedman has i certainly hope we
have some grainy footage of him lying
around we can play right now the wood
from which it's made for all i know
comes from a tree that was cut down in
the state of washington to cut down that
tree
it took a saw
to make the saw it took steel to make
the steel it took iron ore
this black center
we call it lead but it's really graphite
compressed graphite
i'm not sure where it comes from but i
think it comes from some mines in south
america
this red top up here the eraser bitter
rubber
probably comes from malaya where the
rubber tree isn't even native it was
imported from south america by some
businessmen
with the help of the british government
this brass feral
i haven't the slightest idea where it
came from
or the yellow paint or the paint that
made the black lines or the glue
that holds it together literally
thousands of people
cooperated to make this pencil someone
likes his weed
so the moral is obvious it's not like
one person sits in a room and makes a
pencil as a the lady in the pant suit
once said it takes a village
now you can use that pencil to write
whatever you want or to gouge your eyes
out if you're watching the view
but this is the case for everything we
use today it's the division of labor
which is not referring to twins being
born more than 30 minutes apart kat
this clipboard right here the chair i'm
in cat hair extensions they all likely
weren't made by a single entity but a
cooperation of sources workers ideas and
of course labor from people who never
even met each other i wish that was how
this show was produced
imagine if wokism existed before the
pencil was made could the division of
labor exist think of the micro and macro
aggressions why does the pencil have to
be yellow why isn't it black are you
black do you have enough transgender
persons of color making the erasers
what's with the lead talk about a carbon
footprint and why number two why can't
they all be equal fact is nothing would
happen because wokism prevents
cooperation needed for any shared labor
it wouldn't just be pencils but
everything you use you have to work
together whether you like it or not and
sometimes you know we have no choice
take the alec baldwin tragedy
if there wasn't idea segregation that
woman could be alive today because there
would have been an nra instructor on set
and that's cooperation idea sharing sure
baldwin a democrat might not like the
instructor's politics but he's not there
for that he's there to share his safety
expertise and an nra dude would have
kept a loaded gun out of baldwin's hands
idea segregation prevents that wokism
demands you can't benefit from a
person's expertise if they're not like
you the political is now personal
sure you're having engine problems with
your car and your brother-in-law is a
great mechanic but he's got to back the
blue sticker on his truck screw it
you'll just walk home
so now to joe rogan there's likely no
person on earth who's doing more to
dismantle idea segregation than him the
roster of his guests are more diverse
than the olympic opening ceremonies and
they're allowed to speak endlessly about
whatever so the listener can decide it's
the antidote to cable tv where shows
rely on the same people who say the same
things over and over again i mean look
at this show you get 42 minutes of
content divided by five segments and
five talking heads no wonder i'm on
drugs and no wonder cnn hates rogan he's
widening the universe as they shrink it
at first the legacy media tried to take
him down with his coveted content he had
doctors on who disagreed with fauci the
left's patron saint of masks mandates
and mind control but the takedown didn't
take so now some mysterious group
released a supercut of joe saying the
n-word over a decade or so probably
matching what previous democrat senators
and presidents would say in the one
afternoon
the fact that the montage was released
after spotify stuck with rogan tells you
it's less about the word
and more about canning joe he's
apologized sincerely but we all know
like me watching the first magic mike
movie that will never be enough
the n-word is being used as a tool
they're getting desperate they want
rogue destroyed i wonder what the angry
black male has to say
greg
thank you for this time
this is not going to be your normal
everyday angry black man
oh and i'm angry
but not for the reasons you might think
yep joe rogan said the n-word hell he
even said it with a hard ass r
a bunch of times on a podcast
and yeah it pissed me off when i first
saw it
so
very clever woke but you kind of left
out a few things like it was 12 years
ago
nobody cares what he said 12 years ago
hell you didn't where were you then
i'll wait for a response but we know
that will fall on deaf ears
maybe it's time you stop using us
african americans to do your dirty work
and fight your battles
i get it you use your favorite little
words to get us fired up racist systemic
critical
and your new favorite word
misinformation and that'll get us fired
up and we won't even look at the facts
or the whatnots and we'll just jump in
and cancel away with you
your fight with joe rogan was about
covet but you were losing that
conversation so you needed something
else and you went right to the good old
woke playbook
but you went one too many times
how about this fight joe rogan
yourselves leave us out of it
look
the n-word is bad
i learned his meeting at four years old
that was the first time i was called a
by a family member and i've been called
it enough times in my life to where i
pretty much consider myself an expert on
it
now
i know it's going to be a news
flash to you woke but us blacks we
understand the word context
joe rogan should keep that word out his
mouth hell everyone should
he said it then but you're saying it now
for no other reason to cancel a man you
can't compete with
and you know what
that sounds racist to me because that's
usually when i was called it i was
winning the argument
so you had to pull that out of your bag
of tricks because you couldn't compete
i think you just told on your woke
selves
now i just may be an uppity
but that sounds a lot like and i'll use
one of your words
misinformation
that was some good stuff well there you
go you don't have to agree with him or
you can either way we get along like we
always do and he helps me and i help him
that's how it works in life in making
good pencils making good tv and making
good friends
let's welcome tonight's guest
she's all about love and deep spiritual
connections so what the hell is she
doing here former presidential candidate
author and activist marianne williamson
like most bucks he was drawn to this
show by the scent of deer urine
radio and podcast host buck sexton
farmers see his clothes and ask if he'll
help scare crows
walks across america hosts jimmy failure
and she's always first to leave because
her hair is due back by midnight fox
news contributor cat tim
marianne i'm so excited to have you on
the show i've been waiting with baited
breath thank you i was such a fan well
you've been good to me
well you've been good to me thank you
we've been good to each other
what are we doing later no i'm kidding
i saw a great tweet of yours do we have
that it was about joe rogan i don't know
we never do call force here because my
eyes are so bad so i can't even read
that but it says i'm triple vexed but
unless they're standing for hate
or calling for a violent spanning
someone's podcast is too much like
burning a book to me joe rogan should
talk at his podcast about whatever the
damn thing he wants i kind of read what
i could do you still feel that way yes i
do yeah what do you make of this climate
where like people just using whatever
weapon they can to get take people out
well i think nobody has a monopoly on
truth and i think a free society is
where
many voices chime in
and i think um we all need to listen to
each other more than jump to judge each
other and condemn each other and shut
each other down and i don't think either
side of the political spectrum uh should
be too self-congratulatory on this right
i think we all need to self-regulate
right now
i think that things on a certain level
have gone too far
people are talking about how we're sort
of already in a state of emotional
psychological civil war
and i think all of us are having to find
that place where we want to passionately
say what we believe but also
be somewhat careful so i think joe rogan
i agree with what you said i believe
that he was honest and sincere in his
apologies i believe that the angry black
man
tape that we just heard i think there's
context and i think if people really
want to talk about racial issues in
america the issue is not joe rogan the
issue is a mere lock in the minneapolis
police department and the killing of
black men
by police americans needing to ask
ourselves if we're supporting the saudi
government in a genocidal war in yemen
would we be willing to do that if those
people in yemen were white there are
serious issues of race to talk about
right now joe rogan is not one of them
that's my opinion you know i'm glad you
wore that jacket
that's probably the real crime
you know i would are you gonna apologize
for that
this could bring me down every day every
time you're here you just shock me with
the things that you wear
i got range and i would normally come
through now with like a snarky reply but
as a parent
it's just so refreshing to see a small
child without a mask
[Laughter]
you laugh when i make a joke
don't laugh
take that i just stacey abrams your
classroom
so what are your thoughts if you have
any on anything from the pencil or the
no no this this whole thing all right
it's so many points here okay first of
all tyrus is brilliant in saying they
don't care about the use of the n-word
they don't they don't care they care now
it's expedient right now because he's in
the way of their coveted narrative okay
but understand that's why they care it's
the same reason why like jimmy kimmel
and jimmy fallon are always siding with
the regime because if they didn't they'd
get fired because suddenly them wearing
blackface for other at other points in
their career would become viable and it
would become a liability for them but
the thing that drives me crazy really
quick is i'm so sick of this idea that
comedians and even podcast hosts like
rogan who's also a comedian should be
subjected to the same standards of
language as like elected officials like
the whole point of being a comedian that
was the bargain is that you didn't have
to take life seriously right you spend
22 hours a day smoking weed and watching
dirty movies in the la quinta you didn't
sign up for senatorial scrutiny but here
we are no that is that is so true and it
drives me crazy when like the the bozos
at cnn like equate like watching like
this is a four-hour podcast where at
least 50 of the people there are high
they're still in the whole time or yes
it's like and it's like suddenly you're
holding this like standard that you
would for i don't know uh edward r
murrow thank you for that i just that
just popped into my head but nobody can
actually sustain these standards or even
define what they are over the long term
i mean you could you could even look at
this as revolutionary mob mentality
right ask rob spear in the french
revolution ask everybody who worked
around stalin until they didn't anymore
when the [ __ ] power the reality here
is that nobody can actually be pure
enough to withstand the constantly
shifting mechanism of who gets canceled
and on the comedian front by the way i
think a lot of people have gone super
woke because they're afraid if they
don't they need to create a kind of
insurance policy for themselves jimmy
kimmel as carl malone howard stern as a
whole bunch of things back in the day
different sketches and things that were
done when you look at the realities of
who is getting canceled and who's not
all that matters right now is that the
left-wing apparatus wanted to silence
joe rogan and they found a reason they
didn't wait very long right they wanted
to silence him on the issue of covid
right and so they went back and they did
the deep dive and they found the stuff
but they could do this on so many people
and if they actually did it on a lot of
people i think right now who are calling
them out guess what you'd find they
don't withstand the wokeness either don
winslow the author that came out uh
against joe and somebody took all of the
pages from his book where he uses the
n-word and just posted him on twitter it
was quite interesting cat two questions
do you remember the weekend and how was
it
you mean like saturday and sunday yes
yes and
it was it was all right good that's good
some highs and lows yes uh is is that it
that's it okay okay yeah no you can now
address the topic there's so many things
in that in that brilliant monologue i
wouldn't know what to ask you
that is my struggle right now
um yeah look i i again he seems sincere
in his apology and he's sorry and just
like i said with whoopi with everyone
you forgive and you move on because
again everyone says stupid stuff people
like joe rogan or like whoopi are
talking having conversations on a camera
on a podcast and he's doing it like hi a
lot you're gonna there's that's gonna be
there and if what people say they want
who are progressive is they wanna have
these conversations so we can learn from
each other about you know issues such as
race the last way to do that is to say
that because somebody has made mistakes
even if they are sorry and they do learn
from it that they can no longer have a
job ever again yeah crazy
one quick novel idea though really
seriously if you wanted to get anywhere
as a country how about instead of going
after stoner podcast hosts for
discussing coveted remedies we actually
take a look at the genocidal communist
regime who gave it to us is it not
amazing that rogan gets more scrutiny
than china like it's fascinating they
have to be dying laughing right now
because the people that are supposed to
have scrutiny on china whether we're
talking about cnn or whoever else
there's actually a lot of envy around
joe rogan right now that's the reality i
mean i don't mean in this current
situation but i
mean built eight million
eight million viewers a day he is
crushing in terms of relevance all these
other legacy platforms and given i mean
cnn comes to mind because of what
they've just gone through with zucker
but you see what's going on in the
digital space in general and the left is
losing people to rogan as well that's
why they were so upset he was speaking
somewhat from within the tent which was
com that's what's that's apostasy for
them that's why it's so inexcusable
don't use words i don't understand what
show do you think this is gosh
my bad by the way i do i do like this
this is you know standing in solidarity
with bulgarian nightclub owners thank
you everywhere all right hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else